[Music]
space the final frontier
our technology is catching up to Star
Trek so can we now fly the enterprise
shall we begin
No today the enterprise couldn't do half
what the filmmakers imagined we have too
many rules
would you ride your bike without a
helmet we'll get him to buckle up day
and night target will get caught by
contrast the enterprise didn't even have
seatbelts we're at the point where the
enterprise wouldn't get off the ground
of course it would I would be there
William Shatner now mocks me for calling
for less government and that's a
wonderful principle to have government
stay out of our lives and yet how do you
have too many safety rules you don't
know that that wall isn't going to fall
in and if it fell in and then you said
why didn't you make a rule it's good
there rules about cigarette smoking it's
bad for you but it could be worse for me
if I'm smoking if I'm breathing in a
secondhand smoke even on your clothes
that's worth a regulation and they
regulate it they tax it but they don't
ban it well because people want a smoke
yes and free people want to do all kinds
of risky things we ought to be allowed
to tomato soup remember that food
producing machine on the enterprise
there are 14 varieties of tomato soup
available from this replicator you could
get whatever you want it in real life
today's food police would limit your
choices I would like a large Cola your
choice is unavailable fragra your choice
is unavailable and when the crew had to
go regulators would mandate many choices
does this really need to be a fad and
the TSA would make it hard to board no
phasers no try quarters if I catch you
with a tricorder you will not make this
transport this is God ready to be my
fimA the transportation department would
say that's too dangerous
i watch government regulate this and
that and this well I'm trying to do good
I think trying aren't these little men
who've never been on a horse trying to
do good yeah by limiting your broken
bones your argument of no regulations
doesn't I didn't say no regulation well
then where do you draw the line many
many fewer I want to be able to drink
raw milk right well but nobody should be
drinking milk no other species drinks
another species milk if you do it you're
gonna kill yourself all kinds of
terrible things like flatulence will
happen to you darkness has come cuz
today even Captain Kirk doesn't want to
explore space you can't live on Mars a
and B to get three people to Mars is
monumental in in in cost so you're not
gonna populate Mars you're gonna send
some people to die or get out of there
as quickly as possible it's gonna be
like the moon one zero oh come on
private space travel is taking over NASA
no longer insists on government doing it
all we could be entering a wonderful new
era of libertarian exploration we
libertarians would do it differently
will boldly go where no one's going
before discover new species and leave
them alone space the final frontier
our continuing mission to seek out new
life and new civilizations and leave
them alone to trade with them if they
want but to mostly leave them
[Music]
you